dr nabarro i i want to come to the point
that tom toughenham
raised about china in a moment but um
can we just start with the delta variant
uh yes
and what we call the indian variant how
worried are you
well of course by the way hello trevor
and thank you
for the opportunity to hear the
interview just now
i know what you're going to ask me in a
second i just wanted to say
yes uh all variants are
that are being looked at right now that
are identified as variants of concern
are just that they're variants that
collectively we are concerned about and
they are the variants that have either
greater transmission capacity or
the ability to cause worse disease and
all of them are ones that everybody
needs to focus on
but there will continue to be variants
emerging with this virus at intervals
in the foreseeable future so we
shouldn't be surprised by variants
they are to be expected that's par for
the course
so is it the wha's view really that we
are
into uh a world in which
suppression of infection to zero is
impossible and a pointless aim and that
what we really need to do is to learn
how to
live with this thing well you said it
and i would like to
stress to you that humanity is going to
have to
learn how to coexist with this virus
preventing it from spiking and then
surging and causing
hot spots of disease and we're going to
have to be able to do this for the
foreseeable future
eradication is not currently a
reasonable
target for the world one signal
of uh that choice would be
uh an approach to international travel
um from what you've said it sounds like
you
think actually we should return to
international travel
with fewer limitations sooner rather
than later
well like everybody i want life to
start working properly as they say i
want particularly poorer people to be
able to get their incomes back
and i want countries to be able to
re redevelop their economies and so does
the whole of the world health
organization
so our approach when working with
governments
is to encourage them to find ways
quickly to work together on things like
international travel
as well as on things like the sharing of
vaccines
with a global plan we do think that
countries working
separately when trying to do with a
worldwide threat
is not the most efficient way in which
to be doing things
right now understood i've asked you
about the indian variant um
yes of course this week we've seen
something new nepal
and we don't have a lot of information
about that yet but uh
it's thought i think to be potentially
even more transmissible possibly more
lethal
than anything we've seen so far any
signs
from the who's data that could tell us
more
it always takes a number of weeks after
there is a
sudden surge and thoughts perhaps that a
new variant has appeared
to confirm whether or not this is in
fact a variant of concern
there's a group that meets and reviews
the data as you would expect
and so they've looked at the delta
variant the one that was first reported
from india
but as you say there are new reports of
an additional variant coming from nepal
and those will be examined in the coming
days and weeks
and there will know but each time there
is a sudden surge
it does stimulate in one's mind the
thought that there might be a new
variant appearing
that wouldn't be surprising and and as i
said just now
that's the pattern for the future trevor
this virus isn't going away
anytime soon there will be variants
emerging
sometimes we're worried that they're
going to be able to break past the
defense from the vaccines that have been
so brilliantly administered
but we're going to have to work together
on it i describe it as being covered
ready
being ready for whatever this virus
might bring
are you welcoming the prime minister's
ambition
to vaccinate the whole world by the end
of 2022 and more importantly
do you think it's realistic well i was
absolutely delighted to read that
you see we've always said it's going to
take some time for the world to be
vaccinated but for the leader
of the uk and also the chair of the g77
to put a date on it is wonderful because
this now means that there's a real
prospect that when g7 leaders
meet next weekend they will actually
think of a plan
for getting towards everybody being
vaccinated by the end of 2022
and that would change things because
we'll start saying to each other
how do we use this wonderful gift of the
vaccines that are available
as well as possible to help the world
get ahead of this pandemic
rather than focusing on the interests of
individual nations
one of the rec prerequisites for all of
that to happen
is trust between nations and between
leaders
now um let's talk about china last
year the last february the who more or
less absolved
china said it was unlikely that the leak
had
the uh virus had come out of the chinese
laboratory or indeed out of wuhan
um does wha owe the world an apology on
that
oh gosh i i mean i think all of us who
work
in the issue of this pandemic
uh need to be constantly apologizing
because the fact that this pandemic is
causing so much suffering
is something that is a it's a great
distress and the damage being caused the
world is huge and
people like myself who've worked on
pandemic preparedness for
something like two or three decades uh
really
have a huge responsibility why couldn't
we get the world to be better prepared
now when it comes to working with
nations on dealing with a pandemic
as as as you probably know and i'd just
like to stress it for everybody else
the world health organization isn't some
kind of independent superpower that can
just choose to do what it likes where it
likes
it has to work within the rules set by
the governments that own it
we are owned by all the nations of the
world but it has to work with science
though doesn't it
of course so we are on the one hand
trying to do
everything possible to be as straight
and science-based as
as we can but at the same time we have
to decide
where we work and how we work always
trying to make sure that the countries
that we work with approve of what we're
doing
we don't have a carte blanche trevor and
and i want to stress that
we do what we're able to do isn't that
the outcome
the outcome of that though dr nabarro
and i yeah this is not a personal point
at
all okay in the outcome of that that the
nations that are ready to put
pressure on the who political pressure
and china
is first and foremost amongst them get
their way and also they get an easy ride
when it comes to investigation for
example
well i hope not i mean i don't actually
think that anybody
is saying that any one nation gets let
off when it comes to trying to
understand
what's happening about this pandemic for
example
when we're dealing with fact with
pandemics it's a
joint effort between national
governments and the who
we are mutually dependent on each other
and no nation
is let off the hook i and and trevor
inside the who you've got
scientists who just want to do the best
science in the world
and all they do all the time is to push
at countries when countries are
somewhat uh pushing back at us and we
just say
give us what we need and we're not gonna
stop that trevor not gonna stop